Buonasera, questa sera ci aspetta un percorso, come dire, duretto, voi direte anche ieri
sera non era uno scherzo, ma questa sera lo scoppio della seconda guerra mondiale non
è una storia allegra. Le uniche note allegre le mette la partecipazione dell'Italia, qualunque
cosa uno possa pensare di Mussolini, Galeazzo Ciano, eccetera, l'unica nota di commedia
in quelle settimane abbastanza drammatiche l'hanno messa loro, come vedrete. Dunque, come è scoppiata
la seconda guerra mondiale? Beh, è stato scritto che in realtà la seconda guerra mondiale è
scoppiata nel 1919, quando è stato firmato il Trattato di Versailles, il Trattato di
Versailles che ha messo fine alla Prima Guerra Mondiale e ha messo fine alla Prima Guerra Mondiale
creando un'infinità di insoddisfazioni e di frustrazioni. Beh, voi vi ricordate che perfino
l'Italia, che pure ha avuto Trento, Trieste, si è mangiata il Sud Tirolo, però non era contenta,
anzi, da noi si diceva la vittoria mutilata. Perfino l'Italia, vincitrice, è sprofondata
poi quasi nella guerra civile, la dittatura, come conseguenza di quella guerra finita male.
Figuratevi i paesi che hanno perso. La Germania, che ha perso, è uscita dalla Prima Guerra Mondiale,
dal Trattato di Versailles, frustrata, con la sensazione di aver subito un'ingiustizia.
Ingiustizia. Quale ingiustizia? Beh, intanto la Germania aveva dovuto cedere dei territori a un nuovo paese.
Il Trattato di Versailles ha creato tanti nuovi stati, fra cui la Polonia. E la Germania ha ceduto
alla Polonia, ha dovuto cedere alla Polonia un grosso pezzo di territorio abitato da tedeschi
e per di più si sono create delle situazioni ingestibili. C'era una città, oggi non importa più niente a nessuno,
e Gdansk in Polonia, e dai tempi di Lech Wałęsa, che non ne sentiamo più parlare.
Ma all'epoca, invece, se ne discute moltissimo. Danzica, un grande porto, una città tedesca importante,
si trova sul confine tra la nuova Polonia e la Germania. Tutte e due la rivendicano.
I vincitori di Versailles decidono, vabbè, facciamo una città libera, indipendente, né tedesca né polacca.
La città di Danzica è tutta abitata da tedeschi che vorrebbero stare con la Germania, ma non gli viene permesso.
E in Germania comincia immediatamente un movimento di opinione, un po' paragonabile a quello che succedeva
prima della guerra in Italia, Trento, Trieste, l'irredentismo, i fratelli separati.
In Germania si batte Danzica, Danzica è tedesca, Danzica è tedesca, Danzica è tedesca, e non ce l'hanno data.
È una vergogna, bisognerà tornarci su un giorno.
Ma poi ci sono altri problemi che sono nati dalla fine dell'impero austro-ungarico.
L'impero austro-ungarico è stato sciolto, sono nati tanti stati nuovi, l'Austria, l'Ungheria, la Cecoslovacchia.
Con tanti problemi, l'Austria è piccola, è tutta abitata da tedeschi, la maggioranza di loro avrebbero voluto,
vabbè, visto che è finita come è finita, entriamo a far parte della Germania, siamo tedeschi anche noi in Austria.
Ma i vincitori non hanno voluto, l'Austria deve essere indipendente.
E poi la Cecoslovacchia è lo stato dei cechi, degli slovacchi, ma in quelle regioni, al tempo dell'impero austriaco,
abitavano un sacco di tedeschi, cioè di cittadini austriaci di lingua tedesca.
Adesso si ritrovano cittadini cecoslovacchi, ma loro non si sentono cecoslovacchi.
Quindi ci sono questo insieme di problemi creati da Versailles
e che di per sé sono anche problemi comprensibili.
Sono problemi di minoranze all'estero, in gran parte.
Io stasera dovrò parlare per un po' delle cause remote della Seconda Guerra Mondiale.
Io avrei voluto dirvi, benissimo, siamo al 10 agosto del 39 e succede questo.
Lo faremo, ma prima bisogna parlare un po' di queste cause remote, perché se no non capiamo niente.
E allora, le cause remote sono poi queste che vi ho detto.
Una Germania che esce frustrata con una serie di rivendicazioni.
Verso la Polonia per Danzica, verso l'Austria, perché gli austriaci sono tutti tedeschi
e non si capisce perché non devono far parte della Germania.
Verso la cecoslovacchia per i tedeschi che vivono lì e si sentono discriminati.
Nel 1933, in Germania, vincono le elezioni i nazisti e va al potere Hitler.
E Hitler va al potere con un programma che comprende tante belle cose, ma la cosa che i tedeschi
forse sentono di più è che dobbiamo rivedere il trattato di Versailles.
Dobbiamo rivedere l'Europa uscita da Versailles.
È un'Europa ingiusta, è un trattato iniquo.
La Germania ha subito e non è giusto.
Dobbiamo ritornarci su, modificare i confini.
Ecco, la storia di come è scoppiata la Seconda Guerra Mondiale
è, in fondo, è la storia di una doppia illusione.
Una è l'illusione delle grandi potenze democratiche, l'Inghilterra, la Francia,
l'illusione che si potessero anche dare delle soddisfazioni a Hitler,
perché, in fondo, Hitler aveva ragione su certe cose.
L'illusione che si potesse dire, va bene, negoziamo, troviamo un accordo,
d'Anzica, la... ecco, senza provocare grandi sconvolgimenti.
Un'illusione, come vedremo.
L'altra illusione è l'illusione di Hitler
che invece sia possibile riprendersi tutto
e anche qualcosa di più
e trasformare di nuovo la Germania nella grande potenza d'Europa
senza che nessuno si opponga sul serio.
L'illusione delle democrazie, l'illusione delle democrazie occidentali,
la Francia, l'Inghilterra.
C'è un momento in cui il fatto che loro si illudono
viene fuori proprio evidente.
Ecco, la nostra storia di stasera,
alla fine ho deciso di cominciarla in questo giorno.
Il 19 novembre 1937.
Mancano meno di due anni
allo scoppio della Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
lo sappiamo noi, loro non lo sapevano.
Il 19 novembre del 1937
il ministro degli esteri inglese,
Lord Halifax, va a Berlino.
Incontra Hitler
e a Berlino il ministro inglese, Lord Halifax,
esprime simpatia per le rivendicazioni tedesche.
Perché in Inghilterra c'è ormai una generazione
che dice sì, in fondo a Versailles abbiamo esagerato,
alla Germania abbiamo imposto delle cose ingiuste,
in fondo si può capire che i tedeschi chiedano delle revisioni.
Halifax dice a Hitler
l'Inghilterra capisce le vostre rivendicazioni
verso la Polonia, verso l'Austria, verso la Cecoslovacchia
e col tempo
sono anche possibili delle modifiche
dice Lord Halifax a Berlino
purché in modo pacifico
e senza provocare sconvolgimenti.
Lord Halifax dice anche un'altra cosa a Hitler
la Germania
è il baluardo dell'Europa contro il bolshevismo
perché non dobbiamo dimenticarci
per capire come ragionano loro in quegli anni
che c'è anche quest'altra cosa
in Europa
all'est
c'è un convitato di pietra
che si fa finta che non esista
se ne parla il meno possibile
l'Unione Sovietica
c'è l'Unione Sovietica
dove nel 1937 ormai c'è Stalin al potere
noi sappiamo che Stalin
ha messo nel cassetto la rivoluzione mondiale
ma loro non lo sanno
per loro l'Unione Sovietica
per loro, per i politici occidentali
è ancora il paese neanche dei comunisti
dei bolshevichi
dei rivoluzionari
pericolosissimi
è un paese da tenere alla larga
perciò la Germania di Herr Hitler
come dicono i diplomatici inglesi
nei loro rapporti
lo chiamano sempre così
Herr Hitler
la Germania di Herr Hitler
tutto sommato è
col suo anticomunismo feroce
con tutti quei campi di concentramento
in cui ha sbattuto i comunisti tedeschi
ecco
tutto sommato
è un paese utile
e così in Inghilterra
e così in Francia
in Francia dove diversamente dall'Inghilterra
c'è un forte partito comunista
c'è un forte partito socialista
c'è un governo di sinistra
il fronte popolare
oggi ce lo siamo dimenticato
ma all'epoca il fronte popolare
aveva creato
altro che Hollande
aveva creato enormi illusioni
e enormi paure in Francia
e in Francia c'è una classe dirigente
industriali
generali
il clero
che di fronte a un governo comunista
ecco ma meglio i nazisti
ma molto meglio
meglio Hitler
che Stalin
è lo slogan
delle classi dirigenti francesi
in quel momento
dunque
dunque Hitler
percepisce
che c'è un clima
in cui si possono sperare delle cose
si possono fare delle cose
basta aspettare l'occasione
si è molto discusso
se Hitler
ha programmato tutto
fin dall'inizio
aveva i piani precisi
fino ad arrivare a invadere la Polonia
sapete Woody Allen
quando sento Wagner
non so perché
mi viene subito voglia
di invadere la Polonia
ecco
ma l'invasione della Polonia
è soltanto l'ultimo atto
si è molto discusso
Hitler aveva già deciso tutto
fin dall'inizio
forse no
negli anni 60
è uscito un libro famoso
di uno storico inglese
Alan Taylor
il quale dice
ma in fondo Hitler
criminale come era
però in politica estera
voleva delle cose normali
tutti volevano che il loro paese
fosse grande
potente
anche Hitler lo voleva
e aspettava le occasioni buone
annusando l'aria
l'aria tirava buona
aspettare le occasioni
e anche crearle però
le occasioni
Taylor non lo sapeva tanto
i documenti venuti fuori dopo
lo fanno vedere
Hitler le ha create
le occasioni
comincia con l'Austria
l'Austria è un paese tedesco
e quindi in Austria
c'è un partito nazista
che vorrebbe
l'annessione alla Germania
e che prende ordini
da Hitler
Hitler a un certo punto
dà il via libera
ai nazisti
in Austria
creare agitazione
attentati
terrorismo
disordine
assassini
politici
finalmente a un certo momento
è il marzo del 38
sono passati
quattro mesi
dalla visita
di Lord Halifax
a Berlino
quando ha detto
a Hitler
beh in fondo
si può capire
le vostre ragioni
passano quattro mesi
a Vienna
il partito nazista austriaco
fa il colpo di stato
e invita
le truppe tedesche
a entrare in Austria
per garantire
la sicurezza
il 12 marzo
del 38
le truppe tedesche
entrano in Austria
si dice
l'anschluss
come è stato chiamato
l'annessione
si dice
che l'esercito tedesco
a quella data
era così
impreparato
alla guerra
che il 70%
dei veicoli
militari tedeschi
che entrano in Austria
si rompono
prima di entrare
a Vienna
però
all'estero
nessuno reagisce
in Austria
c'è l'entusiasmo
popolare
si fa un plebiscito
che approva
al 99%
l'annessione
alla Germania
nazista
il cardinale
di Vienna
Initzer
dichiara
che i cattolici austriaci
devono ringraziare
il Signore
e obbedire
al nuovo governo
che ci ha liberati
dalla minaccia comunista
e all'estero
nessuno
batte ciglio
in Inghilterra
il Times
di Londra
scrive
ma in fondo
è un po'
come abbiamo fatto
noi due secoli fa
quando la Scozia
si è unita
all'Inghilterra
sono cose
abbastanza normali
la gente
lo voleva
Hitler
prende nota
ha annesso
l'Austria
e nessuno
ha reagito
passano pochi giorni
ma davvero pochi giorni
ancora in quel marzo
del 38
Hitler
convoca il capo
dei nazisti
cecoslovacchi
perché anche in
cecoslovacchia
c'è un partito nazista
nella minoranza
tedesca
dei sudeti
si chiamano così
non mi ricordo mai perché
ma i tedeschi
di cecoslovacchia
si chiamano
i sudeti
fra i tedeschi
di cecoslovacchia
c'è un partito nazista
che prende ordini
da Hitler
e nel marzo
del 38
Hitler
dà il via
a cominciare
con la violenza
di piazza
le agitazioni
il terrorismo
la cecoslovacchia
comincia a sprofondare
nel caos
la stampa tedesca
comincia una campagna
pesantissima
i tedeschi
in cecoslovacchia
sono oppressi
sono una minoranza
discriminata
oppressa
la polizia
cecoslovacca
criminale
arresta
violenta
tortura
i tedeschi
in cecoslovacchia
soffrono
non si può sopportare
gli ambasciatori inglesi
a Berlino
a Praga
su istruzioni
del loro governo
dicono
beh ma in fondo
i tedeschi
non sono mica tutti
torti
si può capire
ripetono
che le rivendicazioni
tedesche
in fondo
sono fondate
che è il governo
cecoslovacco
che deve cercare
di venire un po'
incontro
a quello che chiedono
i tedeschi
non vogliamo mica
scatenare un'altra guerra
no?
e quindi
il governo
cecoslovacco
farebbe meglio
a fare delle concessioni
c'è un solo paese
che in quel momento
quando i nazisti
in cecoslovacchia
cominciano lo stesso gioco
che avevano fatto
in Austria
c'è un solo paese
che in quel momento
prende una posizione
pubblica
e dice
bisognerebbe
che tutte le potenze
si mettessero d'accordo
per garantire
la cecoslovacchia
e l'unione sovietica
e ovviamente
non la sta a sentire
nessuno
perché la cecoslovacchia
è il paese
l'unione sovietica
bolscevico
comunista
è fuori dal gioco
l'ambasciatore inglese
a Mosca
in quelle settimane
manda un rapporto
a Londra
in cui conclude
la Russia
cito
va considerata
fuori
della politica europea
la Russia
possiamo far finta
che non esista
notate ancora
la fatica
di prendere atto
di come cambia il mondo
loro continuano
a parlare
della politica europea
come se a fare
la politica
fossero ancora sempre
l'Inghilterra
la Francia
ecco no
gli Stati Uniti
non ci sono
il Giappone
l'Unione
niente
è ancora sempre
la politica europea
e la Russia
non conta
si va avanti
per mesi
con la cecoslovacchia
nel caos
e la stampa tedesca
che batte
batte batte
sulle sofferenze
dei sudeti
e l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
che premono
col governo
di Praga
dicendo
ma fate
delle concessioni
finalmente
si arriva
a settembre
la situazione
è così pesante
che il governo inglese
e il governo francese
decidono
che bisogna
costringere
i cecoslovacchi
a fare
delle concessioni
a Hitler
bisogna inventarsi
qualcosa
bisognerebbe inventarsi
una conferenza
oggi si direbbe
un tavolo
di trattative
allora non si erano
ancora inventati
il tavolo
e neanche il vertice
bisognerebbe fare
una conferenza
dicono loro
come facciamo
a convincere
Hitler
a accettare
un tavolo
di trattative
chiediamo
a Mussolini
tanto sono amici
gli inglesi
e i francesi
si rivolgono
a Mussolini
e gli dicono
in sostanza
sintetizzo
senti un po'
Hitler
se è disposto
a fare in modo
che ci incontriamo
tutti
e ci mettiamo
d'accordo
per venire
incontro
alle richieste
tedesche
sulla cecoslovacchia
Hitler
è d'accordo
il 29
settembre
del 1938
c'è quella pagina
che poi è stata
sempre deplorata
come dire
uno dei momenti
bassi
della politica europea
anche se
almeno due
dei quattro
protagonisti
erano in buona fede
la conferenza
di Monaco
a Monaco
di Baviera
si incontrano
Hitler
Mussolini
il primo
ministro inglese
Chamberlain
Neville
e il primo
ministro francese
Dalladier
almeno
Chamberlain
e Dalladier
sono in buona fede
su questo
è difficile
avere dubbi
loro hanno
un incubo
come tutta
la generazione
che ha visto
la prima guerra
mondiale
come tutta
la generazione
che ha visto
il macello
della prima guerra
mondiale
i politici
di quegli anni
hanno in mente
quando c'è una crisi
una cosa sola
tutto
ma non
una nuova guerra
mai più
una guerra
a nessun costo
o se preferite
la pace
a qualunque costo
qual è il qualunque costo?
e beh
se la cecoslovacchia
deve cedere
un pezzo di territorio
alla Germania
pazienza
meglio questo
la conferenza
di Monaco
sono
Inghilterra
Francia
Italia
e Germania
che si riuniscono
per decidere
quale pezzo
di cecoslovacchia
sarà ceduto
alla Germania
i cecoslovacchi
sono fuori
della porta
che aspettano
di sapere
cosa viene deciso
e la conferenza
di Monaco
decide
tutto il pezzo
popolato
da tedeschi
i suddeti
viene ceduto
alla Germania
Hitler
prende nota
non solo
non mi hanno ostacolato
mi hanno addirittura
aiutato
a prendermi
un pezzo
di cecoslovacchia
e qui
come dire
appunto
l'ho detto
io non so
è difficile
parlarne
perché da un lato
viene da dire
come si è detto
per 50 anni
ma che tragedia
dei politici
di quel livello
però
quelli erano politici
come dire
di primo livello
che non hanno capito
cosa stava succedendo
ed erano in buona fede
Chamberlain
torna a Londra
è stato poi sbeffeggiato
fino ad oggi
per questo suo ritorno
a Londra
da Monaco
Chamberlain torna a Londra
già mentre scende
la scaletta dell'aereo
sventola
il foglio
con gli accordi
voi capite
ci sono i fotografi
la folla
tutto intorno
Chamberlain sventola
il foglio
e dice
alla folla
ve lo traduco
direttamente
il discorso di Chamberlain
alla folla
quel primo giorno
scendendo dall'aereo
da Monaco
la sistemazione
del problema
cecoslovaco
che adesso
abbiamo raggiunto
secondo me
è solo l'inizio
di una sistemazione
più ampia
in cui tutta l'Europa
potrà trovare
la pace
siamo undici mesi
prima dello scoppio
della seconda guerra mondiale
ricordiamocelo
Chamberlain dice
questa mattina
ho avuto un altro incontro
col cancelliere tedesco
Herr Hitler
e qui c'è il trattato
che porta la sua firma
e la mia
noi consideriamo
il trattato
segnato ieri notte
come il simbolo
del desiderio
dei nostri due popoli
di non andare
mai più
in guerra
l'uno contro l'altro
miei cari amici
il primo ministro
britannico
è tornato
dalla Germania
portando la pace
con onore
io credo
che sia la pace
per il nostro tempo
andate a casa
e fatevi una bella
dormita tranquilla
questo è il discorso
di Chamberlain
alla folla di Londra
tornando da Monaco
la politica di Chamberlain
è un nome preciso
che poi è diventato
nel gergo
della politica inglese
lo rivedremo domani sera
parlando della signora Thatcher
è diventato
una brutta parola
appeasement
la pacificazione
la pace
costi
quel che costi
e la piecement
oggi effettivamente
è scioccante
non si rendevano conto
no non si rendevano conto
l'ironia tragica
di questo
è che loro
erano disposti
a tutto
pur di non far
scoppiare
la guerra
e il risultato
è che l'hanno fatta
scoppiare
ben inteso
Hitler era bravo
Hitler era abilissimo
a menare il camperlaie
e a ingannare
gli interlocutori
a Monaco
Hitler dice
a Chamberlain
ecco questo sentite
questo lo riferisce
a Chamberlain
dice ho parlato
con Hitler
parlando
con grande
sincerità
Hitler
mi ha detto
che questa
era l'ultima
delle sue
ambizioni
territoriali
in Europa
e l'ha detto
Hitler
era così sincero
quindi
dormite
sonni tranquilli
ma Chamberlain
non è
Chamberlain
è dalla D.E.
non sono gli unici
che si fanno
a parte Mussolini
che anche lui
ci crede
ma ci crede
perfino la Polonia
la Polonia
ricordiamocelo
sarà poi lei
la vittima
quando scoppia la guerra
la Polonia
quando si fa
la spartizione
della Cecoslovacchia
decisa a Monaco
ne approfitta
e si prende
anche lei
un pezzetto
di Cecoslovacchia
Polonia
è un paese
militarista
governato
dai colonnelli
una mezza democrazia
autoritaria
nazionalista
anticomunista
al massimo
in quel momento
i polacchi
sono convinti
che con Hitler
si può fare amicizia
tanto siamo anticomunisti
tutti
chi è più anticomunista
di Hitler
noi polacchi
ancora di più
quindi i polacchi
in quei mesi
fine 38
inizio 39
credono di essere
amici di Hitler
e Hitler
il 30 gennaio
del 39
mancano sette mesi
allo scoppio
della guerra mondiale
Hitler quel giorno
al Reichstag
al Parlamento tedesco
dice
l'amicizia
fra Germania
e Polonia
è uno dei fattori
rassicuranti
nella vita politica
dell'Europa
il ministro degli esteri
polacco
Beck
va a Berlino
a fine gennaio
del 39
anno degli incontri
con Hitler
in cui
Beck
non nasconde
che certo
alla Polonia
piacerebbe
allargarsi
verso l'Unione
Sovietica
prendersi
un pezzo
di Ucraina
lì ci sono
minoranze
polacche
e in fondo
in futuro
si potrebbe
anche parlarne
nel frattempo
mentre si fanno
questi bei discorsi
gennaio
febbraio
marzo
del 39
la cecoslovacchia
si sfascia
ha perso
tutta la fascia
abitata dai tedeschi
ha perso
il grosso
delle sue industrie
ha perso
le sue fortificazioni
di confine
a questo punto
la slovacchia
vuole diventare
indipendente
è una vecchia storia
voi lo sapete
poi è successo
attualmente
è indipendente
si è separata
la cecoslovacchia
sprofonda
sta per essere
invasa dall'Ungheria
a un certo punto
Hitler decide
di liquidare
il problema
il 14 marzo
del 39
Hitler
ordina
al presidente
cecoslovacco
di venire
a parlargli
a Berlino
il presidente
cecoslovacco
obbedisce
arriva a Berlino
e all'alba
del 15 marzo
Hitler
lo informa
che l'esercito
tedesco
sta per entrare
in cecoslovacchia
per mantenere
l'ordine
e che il presidente
cecoslovacco
deve firmare
un foglio
dove dice
che l'ha chiesto
lui
altrimenti
Praga
sarà rasa
al suolo
dalla Luftwaffe
il presidente
prima ha un infarto
e poi con i medici
che lo tengono
sveglio
firma la richiesta
di intervento tedesco
il 15 marzo
i tedeschi
invadono la cecoslovacchia
nel mondo
nessuno interviene
Hitler
prende nota
neanche stavolta
è intervenuto
nessuno
però
voi direte
era ora
Chamberlain
comincia a pensare
che forse
non ci si può fidare
di Hitler
dopo tutto
due giorni dopo
Chamberlain
parla alla Camera
dei Comuni
17 marzo
vi traduco il discorso
di Chamberlain
il quale
evidentemente
dice delle cose
che proprio
non vorrebbe dire
si sente
è una sintassi
dice Chamberlain
ma non ci viene
in mente
inevitabilmente
questa domanda
ma se è così
facile
scoprire
buone ragioni
per ignorare
delle garanzie
date in modo
così solenne
e così ripetuto
ma allora
che affidamento
possiamo fare
su altre garanzie
che ci verranno
dalla stessa parte
questo è
l'ultimo attacco
contro un piccolo
stato
oppure
sarà seguito
da altri
non è che
questo è un passo
nella direzione
di un tentativo
di dominare
il mondo
con la forza
Chamberlain
evidentemente
spera che gli dicano
no
stai tranquillo
però il dubbio
il dubbio
comincia a venire
la controprova
arriva subito
i tedeschi
hanno invaso
la cecoslovacchia
il 15 marzo
dieci giorni dopo
il 26 marzo
Hitler
presenta
al governo polacco
la richiesta
di annettere
la città libera
di Danzica
i polacchi
rifiutano
Hitler
parla al Reichstag
fine aprile
del 38
tre mesi prima
nello stesso posto
Hitler ha detto
l'amicizia
fra Germania
e Polonia
è uno dei fondamenti
rassicuranti
della politica europea
tre mesi dopo
questo di Danzica
è forse
il problema
più doloroso
per la Germania
io pensavo
che la sua
soluzione pacifica
avrebbe contribuito
ad allentare
definitivamente
la tensione
in Europa
il governo polacco
ha rifiutato
la mia offerta
mi dispiace
moltissimo
di questo
atteggiamento
incomprensibile
del governo polacco
a partire
da quel momento
a Danzica
sul confine
fra Danzica
e la Polonia
cominciano i conflitti
gli incidenti
le sparatorie
a Danzica
si formano
milizie naziste
fuori c'è
la dogana polacca
incidenti
tutti i giorni
però
stavolta
il governo inglese
e il governo francese
stanno cominciando
a pensare
che forse
è il caso
di fare qualcosa
cosa?
l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
propongono
ai polacchi
di negoziare
un trattato
di alleanza
e anzi
Chamberlain
si spinge
fino a garantire
ufficialmente
che anche se
il trattato
non è ancora firmato
se la Polonia
fosse attaccata
da qualcuno
chissà chi
ma se fosse attaccata
da qualcuno
l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
sono pronte
a difenderla
la Polonia
oh tenete conto
oggi col senno
di poi
uno dice
era anche ora
cos'altro vuoi fare
ma all'epoca
far digerire
questa cosa
all'opinione pubblica
è difficilissimo
all'epoca
l'opinione pubblica
in Inghilterra
e in Francia
dice
Danzica
e noi dovremmo
fare la guerra
per Danzica
sui giornali
escono i titoloni
morire per Danzica
no
tuttavia
il governo francese
e il governo inglese
impavidi
avendo scoperto
che forse di Hitler
non ci si può fidare
nell'aprile
maggio
del 39
fanno anche
un'altra cosa
inaudita
cominciano
a vedere
se non si può
fare
una qualche
forma
di accordo
con l'unione
sovietica
e cominciano
un negoziato
che durerà
molti mesi
per vedere
se si può
fare
un accordo
di difesa
militare
nel caso
che ci fosse
una guerra
la storia
di questa
trattativa
è una storia
triste
e deprimente
perché
uno dice
beh magari
l'avessero fatto
questo accordo
invece si vede
che non lo vuole
fare veramente
nessuno
hanno tutti paura
gli uni degli altri
quello che si vede
è un dato
che sembra oggettivo
perché si basa
sui telegrammi
che partono
e sulle risposte
ogni volta
che l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
fanno una proposta
ai russi
i russi rispondono
il giorno dopo
poi passano
settimane
finalmente
gli inglesi
e i francesi
fanno il passo
successivo
i russi rispondono
il giorno dopo
e si va avanti
così
con questo negoziato
che si trascina
però intanto
Stalin prende nota
questi mi stanno
chiedendo di negoziare
ma ci credono
o mi vogliono
tirare dentro
e poi al momento
buono mi mollano
a occuparmene
io
della Germania
Stalin prende nota
e decide
che non si può
rischiare
sta negoziando
con l'Inghilterra
e con la Francia
un accordo militare
ma gli inglesi
e i francesi
sembrano molto
tiepidi
Stalin fa sapere
ai tedeschi
che anche se
i loro paesi
sono nemici
uno è comunista
l'altro
però
hanno degli interessi
commerciali
forse aprire
un negoziato
per un accordo
commerciale
fra Germania
e Unione Sovietica
potrebbe anche
essere una buona idea
i tedeschi
ci stanno
e quindi
comincia questa situazione
che attraversa
tutta l'estate
Stalin
senza che nessuno
lo sappia
sta negoziando
contemporaneamente
con l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
su un tavolo
e con la Germania
su un altro
stando a vedere
cosa succede
e l'Italia
l'Italia
è amicissima
della Germania nazista
il 22 maggio
firmano
il patto d'acciaio
fra l'entusiasmo
della stampa
amicizia
indefettibile
fra i nostri due popoli
ma in realtà
Mussolini
è preoccupato
perché i nazisti
gli hanno garantito
che non vogliono
fare la guerra
per il momento
ma lui comincia
a non essere più
così sicuro
e la prima cosa
che dobbiamo avere
ben chiara
non sempre
lo si dice così chiaramente
anche se insomma
è ben noto
è documentato
come mai
Mussolini
non è tanto sicuro
perché l'Italia
in quel momento
è completamente
priva di risorse
l'Italia
ha fatto
la guerra
d'Etiopia
e ha fatto
la guerra
di Spagna
l'intervento
in Spagna
a fianco
di Franco
è andato
tutto bene
la guerra
d'Etiopia
è un trionfo
anche in Spagna
è andata
abbastanza bene
ma le guerre
costano
delle cifre
terrificanti
la guerra
d'Etiopia
e la guerra
di Spagna
vogliono dire
che nel bilancio
italiano
c'è una voragine
non c'è più
un soldo
per niente
specialmente
non c'è più
un soldo
per armi moderne
ora
il caso vuole
che in quegli ultimi anni
siccome tutti
hanno capito
l'aria che tira
tutti i paesi
stanno sperimentando
nuove armi
in tutti i paesi
stanno mettendo
in produzione
dei caccia
di nuova concezione
lo Spitfire
nuovi carri armati
gli armamenti
che andavano bene
fino a due o tre anni fa
stanno invecchiando
rapidamente
l'unico paese
che non ha i soldi
per farlo
è l'Italia
Mussolini lo sa
anche se poi
ogni tanto
preferisce
dimenticarselo
ma lo sa
in quel momento
nell'estate del 39
ha una preoccupazione
che ai tedeschi
non venga in mente
di fare la guerra
ai primi di agosto
Ciano
scrive nel diario
sapete
Galeazzo Ciano
ministro degli esteri
genero di Mussolini
che poi sarà fucilato
cinque anni dopo
dopo il processo di Verona
ma questa è un'altra storia
ai primi di agosto
Ciano
il nostro ministro degli esteri
annota nel diario
è venuto il momento
di vedere
come stanno le cose
il gioco
è troppo grosso
perciò Ciano
vola in Germania
l'11 agosto
incontra il suo collega
il ministro degli esteri
tedesco
von Ribbentrop
Ciano
è mandato da Ribbentrop
con l'incarico
di spiegargli
che fare una guerra
in quel momento
sarebbe una follia
non bisogna assolutamente
farla
Ciano chiede a Ribbentrop
ma
tutta questa storia
che state sollevando
sulla Polonia
cos'è che volete?
volete Danzica?
Ribbentrop gli risponde
ormai non più
vogliamo la guerra
sono a un ricevimento
sono tutti lì
con le coppie di champagne
in mano
Ciano
freme dalla voglia
di dire ai suoi collaboratori
quello che gli ha appena detto
Ribbentrop
ma sono lì al ricevimento
tutte queste cose
le scrive poi Ciano
nel suo diario
finalmente passa vicino
a uno dei suoi collaboratori
Ciano
e gli fa all'orecchio
siamo alle botte
dopodiché Ciano
parla ancora con Ribbentrop
e Ribbentrop gli dice
sì faremo la guerra
alla Polonia
ormai è deciso
la schiacciamo la Polonia
e dice
ma è l'Inghilterra
la Francia
e Ribbentrop gli dice
vedrai
non interverranno
e la scommessa
come nel 1914
per chi di voi
c'era ieri sera
e la scommessa
non interverranno
salvo che stavolta
sapete che la storia
si ripete
prima tragedia
e poi farsa
stavolta fanno
la scommessa davvero
nel senso che Ribbentrop
dice a Ciano
dai scommettiamo
scommettiamo che non intervengono
se vinco io
mi dovete regalare
un bel quadro rinascimentale
italiano
se vinci tu
ti regalo una collezione
di armi antiche tedesche
ma vedrai
vinco io
non interverranno
faremo la guerra
e non diventerà
una guerra mondiale
perché la Francia
e l'Inghilterra
non oseranno intervenire
finisce la cena di gala
finisce il ricevimento
i brindisi
tutto
Ciano torna
con gli altri suoi collaboratori
all'albergo
brucia dalla voglia
di raccontargli tutto
sono in albergo
gli viene il dubbio
che forse i tedeschi
hanno messo dei microfoni
nella stanza
allora si chiudono
in bagno
e chiusi in bagno
Ciano racconta
ai suoi collaboratori
che i tedeschi
ormai
hanno deciso
di fare la guerra
e qui
comincia il conto
alla rovescia
12 agosto
il giorno dopo
l'intervista di Ciano
con Ribbentrop
sabato
12 agosto
è ferragosto
questa guerra
come la prima
scoppia in piena estate
all'epoca
non ci sono ancora
tante ferie
ma un po' ci sono
a ferragosto
la gente va via
sabato 12 agosto
per esempio
Milano
si svuota
mezzo milione
di persone
prendono il treno
per andare al mare
quello stesso giorno
arriva a Mosca
la delegazione
franco-inglese
finalmente
dopo mesi
che ne parlano
mandano una delegazione
a Mosca
per negoziare
un trattato
i sovietici
sono molto delusi
la delegazione
è fatta
di un generale
francese
e un ammiraglio
inglese
personaggi di
secondo piano
i russi
gli chiedono
ma avete pieni poteri
per firmare
un trattato
questa cosa
mi fermo un secondo
dei pieni poteri
è importantissima
per scapire
gli scambi diplomatici
di quest'epoca
in cui per carità
c'è il telefono
c'è il telegrafo
l'aeroplano
però poi
avere sul posto
uno che può
firmare
è una cosa
che tutti
considerano fondamentale
i sovietici
chiedono
siete venuti
a trattare
benissimo
c'è urgenza
avete pieni poteri
e il generale
francese
e l'ammiraglio
inglese
rispondono
no
voi ci dite
noi riferiamo
i sovietici
rimangono molto
delusi
lo stesso giorno
il governo
sovietico
fa arrivare
un invito
a Berlino
sarebbe bene
che Ribbentrop
venisse a Mosca
perché abbiamo
da parlarci
domenica
13 agosto
piena estate
vacanze
la mostra del cinema
a Venezia
Maria Bellonci
vince il premio
Viareggio
con Lucrezia Borgia
quello stesso giorno
Hitler
telefona a Mussolini
è proprio così
come ti ha detto
Ciano
faremo la guerra
alla Polonia
al primo incidente
attacchiamo
non solo
Hitler spiega
siamo a metà agosto
i miei generali
hanno calcolato
che per sconfiggere
la Polonia
ci vuole un mese e mezzo
sei settimane
massimo
ora
a metà ottobre
arriva l'autunno
in Polonia
le strade
e gli aeroporti
diventano inutilizzabili
per il fango
quindi entro
metà ottobre
bisogna aver finito
ci serve un mese e mezzo
quindi entro fine agosto
noi attacchiamo
Mussolini
e gli altri
in Italia
sono allibiti
Ciano
annota nel diario
ci hanno ingannato
e mentito
lunedì
14 agosto
clima vacanziero
c'è il festival
di Salisburgo
Hitler
che è in montagna
va al festival
di Salisburgo
il ratto dal serraglio
di Mozart
a Mosca
i russi incontrano
la delegazione
anglo-francese
e mettono
le carte in tavola
vogliamo fare
un accordo
per difendere
la Polonia
va bene
però noi vogliamo
la garanzia
che si fa sul serio
che i polacchi
lasciano entrare
le truppe russe
su territorio polacco
se c'è la guerra
sono in buona fede
sono in mala fede
stanno già pensando
di mangiarsela
la Polonia
oppure pensano sul serio
che se si deve fare la guerra
bisogna farla sul serio
non si sa
intanto dicono questo
cosa rispondono
l'ammiraglio inglese
e il generale francese
non è di nostra competenza
noi dobbiamo riferire
riferiremo a Parigi
e a Londra
vedremo
quello stesso lunedì
14 agosto
Ribbentrop decide
che l'idea dei russi
che lui vada a Mosca
è una buona idea
ci andrà
martedì 15 agosto
ferragosto
il generale francese
ha scritto a Parigi
i russi vogliono
per firmare l'accordo
la garanzia che i polacchi
in caso di guerra
li lasciano entrare
bisogna chiedere
ai polacchi
il ministro degli esteri
francese Bonnet
cerca l'ambasciatore polacco
dov'è secondo voi
l'ambasciatore polacco
a ferragosto?
al mare
e al mare
lo fanno tornare a Parigi
gli dicono
concedete il passaggio
ai russi
in caso di guerra
contro la Germania
l'ambasciatore dice
devo chiedere a Varsavia
ma secondo me
diranno di no
perché dei russi
abbiamo ancora più paura
che dei tedeschi
il ministro francese Bonnet
avverte l'ambasciatore polacco
guardate che a noi risulta
che Hitler
ha dichiarato
che liquiderà
la Polonia
in tre settimane
l'ambasciatore polacco
risponde
questo è importante
per capire anche lì
il clima
e com'era questo regime polacco
l'ambasciatore polacco
risponde
sarà la Polonia
a invadere la Germania
fin dai primi giorni
mercoledì 16 agosto
Ribbentrop scrive a Mosca
vengo
è la prima volta
che mettono per iscritto
che farà questo viaggio
per firmare un trattato
con i sovietici
a Berlino
i tedeschi
cominciano a preoccuparsi
di una cosa
chi di voi c'era ieri sera
mi scuserà
la storia a volte si ripete
i tedeschi si dicono
e l'Inghilterra
cosa farà
perciò
al ministero degli esteri
convocano l'ambasciatore inglese
e gli dicono
ma non è che voi appoggiate
la Polonia
lo vedete che pazzi sono
questi polacchi
le provocazioni
la minoranza tedesca
in Polonia è oppressa
è tutta colpa dei polacchi
che non sono gente ragionevole
ma voi inglesi
non sarete mica disposti
ad aiutare dei pazzi
vero?
l'ambasciatore inglese
risponde
che se i tedeschi
si sono fatti questa idea
si sbagliano di grosso
che non hanno capito niente
della mentalità inglese
e che non c'è ombra di dubbio
che se la Polonia
è attaccata
l'Inghilterra
la aiuterà
giovedì 17 agosto
sulla frontiera
fra Germania e Polonia
si moltiplicano gli incidenti
sparatori e sconfinamenti
la stampa tedesca
scatena una campagna
ricordate la cecoslovacchia
l'anno prima
la stampa tedesca
scatena una campagna
terrore polacco
contro la minoranza tedesca
arresti
omicidi
a Mosca
arriva la risposta
di Ribbentrop
sono disposto
a venire
a firmare un accordo
venerdì 18 agosto
come sapete
Mussolini e Ciano
sono terrorizzati
perché l'Italia
non è pronta
a fare la guerra
ma la linea
ufficiale
che viene dettata
alla stampa italiana
ovviamente
è tutt'altra
abbiamo fatto
il patto d'acciaio
la stampa italiana
ha ordini precisi
in questa crisi
i tedeschi
hanno ragione
perciò vi leggo
alcuni titoli
dal Corriere della Sera
del 18 agosto
le tragiche responsabilità
delle democrazie
naturalmente democrazia
è una brutta parola
nell'Italia fascista
che hanno scatenata
e sorretta
la protervia polacca
l'incrollabile
fermezza
dell'asse
contro il bellicismo
ammantato
di ipocrisia
degli accerchiatori
dove gli accerchiatori
sono appunto
le demopluto-giudocrazie
Francia-Inghilterra
Unione Sovietica
che assediano
i popoli
lo sapete
insomma
questa storia
la sappiamo
in Italia
quello stesso
venerdì 18 agosto
il governo polacco
deve decidere
se si fa l'alleanza
con l'Unione Sovietica
ma concedendo
il passaggio
alle truppe sovietiche
il governo polacco
dice di no
non abbiamo accordi militari
con l'Unione Sovietica
e non desideriamo
averne
qui c'è anche
un famoso commento
che è diventato poi
proverbiale
di un generale polacco
il quale dichiara
con i tedeschi
rischiamo di perdere
la nostra libertà
con i russi
perdiamo
la nostra anima
perciò
nessun accordo
sabato
19 agosto
a Mosca
arriva la notizia
che i polacchi
non vogliono
l'accordo con la Russia
perciò
il negoziato
si arena
il ministro
degli esteri
sovietico
Molotov
scrive
a Berlino
dicendo
allora a questo punto
venga Ribbentrop
vogliamo vederci
il 26
o il 27
domenica
20 agosto
telegramma
di Hitler
a Stalin
tenete conto
che è la prima
volta
nella storia
che un capo
di governo
occidentale
scrive
personalmente
al capo
del governo
sovietico
fino a quel momento
l'Unione Sovietica
era come un paese
di appestati
con loro si parlava
solo indirettamente
sotto banco
il primo telegramma
di un governante
occidentale
a Stalin
e di Hitler
il quale
il 20 agosto
gli dice
sono contento
che avete accettato
di vedere Ribbentrop
ma perché il 26
facciamo prima
facciamo il 22
o il 23
lunedì
21 agosto
Mussolini
e Ciano
si rompono
la testa
per cercare
un modo
di evitare
la guerra
gli viene in mente
di fare come
l'anno scorso
una bella conferenza
a Monaco
una conferenza
internazionale
in cui ci si mette
tutti d'accordo
perciò
telefonano
a Berlino
per parlare
col ministro degli esteri
von Ribbentrop
e proporgli
questa bella idea
dal diario
di Ciano
Ribbentrop
non si fa trovare
finalmente
nel pomeriggio
Ribbentrop risponde
e dice
adesso non posso
discutere di queste cose
sono in attesa
di un importante
messaggio
da Mosca
quel giorno
in effetti
il 21 agosto
Stalin riceve
il telegramma
di Hitler
alle 3 del pomeriggio
e alle 5 del pomeriggio
risponde
certo
facciamo prima
Ribbentrop
può venire a Mosca
anche dopo domani
il 23
e firmiamo
un patto
di non aggressione
fra Germania
e Unione Sovietica
oh
fermiamoci
su questa cosa
è una decisione
cruciale
una di quelle
che hanno contribuito
fortemente
a far succedere
quel che è successo
è una decisione
assolutamente
imprevista
e scioccante
su questo
bisogna essere
molto chiari
perché
vabbè vi dico
una mia opinione
qualcuno non sarà
d'accordo
ma da molti anni
ci hanno fatto
il lavaggio del cervello
dicendoci che i totalitarismi
sono tutti uguali
che l'Unione Sovietica
di Stalin
e la Germania
di Hitler
era la stessa cosa
e allora anche
il loro accordo
sembra meno strano
la realtà
è che per allora
per la gente
di allora
è uno shock
immenso
perché la Germania
nazista
e la Unione Sovietica
comunista
appaiono come i due
paesi più contrari
e nemici
che ci siano
e lo sono
è una prova
del cinismo
dell'astuzia
e della freddezza
straordinarie
sia dei nazisti
sia di Stalin
e del suo gruppo
il fatto
che facciano
questo accordo
da cui il mondo
rimane
è sterrefatto
Stalin ha deciso
che gli inglesi
e i francesi
sono troppo molli
non lo vogliono
l'accordo
perciò lo faccio
con i nazisti
alla faccia loro
perché io ho bisogno
di essere sicuro
vi aggiungo
una piccola cosa
questa è una cosa
che pochi sanno
magari anche molti
di voi non la sanno
un piccolo pezzetto
del contesto
di quei giorni
quando Stalin decide
che visto che le cose
stanno andando
molto male
come dice Ciano
siamo alle botte
ecco Stalin decide
che ha bisogno
assoluto di sicurezza
anche a costo
di fare il patto
col diavolo
tanto poi
non lo manterremo
il patto
ma per il momento
ci serve
qual è il piccolo
pezzetto di contesto
che all'epoca
nessuno conosce
e anche oggi
pochi si ricordano
in quegli stessi giorni
l'Unione Sovietica
sta combattendo
una guerra segreta
e non dichiarata
col Giappone
in Mongolia
che è una repubblica
comunista alleata
dei sovietici
e confina
col Manchukuo cinese
occupato
dai giapponesi
nell'estate
del 39
è in corso
una guerra
in piena regola
che coinvolge
interi corpi
d'armata
una guerra
che alla fine
farà 70.000
morti e feriti
ma che i due
governi
sono d'accordo
di non rivelare
al mondo
e il mondo
non viene a sapere
niente
figuratevi
i confini
tra la Mongolia
e la Manciuria
è una guerra
in piena regola
perché i giapponesi
dalla Cina
stanno sconfinando
in Mongolia
i mongoli
chiedono aiuto
ai sovietici
i sovietici
vengono
poi fra parentesi
la guerra
la stravincono
i sovietici
che sono al comando
di un generale
che poi diventerà famoso
Zhukov
che arriverà
anche a Berlino
fra sei anni
Zhukov
sbaraglia i giapponesi
e sta succedendo
in quei giorni
l'attacco di Zhukov
scatta il 20 agosto
il 21
con la battaglia
in corso
Stale indecide
facciamo il patto
con la Germania
perché comunque
almeno un confine
ce lo dobbiamo garantire
quel giorno stesso
la notizia
viene resa pubblica
Mussolini e Ciano
sono sconvolti
come tutto il mondo
dall'accordo
fra Germania
e Unione Sovietica
sono sconvolti
ma anche ammirati
sono forti
questi tedeschi
il diario di Ciano
non c'è dubbio
che i tedeschi
hanno fatto un colpo
da maestri
la situazione europea
è sconvolta
poi Ciano
fa una considerazione
astuta
l'Inghilterra
e ancora di più
la Francia
sono pieni di comunisti
come faranno adesso
con tutti i comunisti
che hanno in casa
a fare la guerra
contro la Germania
che è amica
dell'Unione Sovietica
all'improvviso
e poi c'è la conclusione
di Ciano
che vi cito
perché comunque
è emblematica
del linguaggio
e del livello morale
del regime
Ciano conclude
nel suo diario
conviene attendere
e se è possibile
tenerci pronti
a fare anche noi
la nostra parte
di bottino
martedì 22 agosto
Hitler convoca
i generali
e dà gli ultimi ordini
per la guerra
dice
il momento
è quello buono
è come nel 14
ricordate
il momento buono
dobbiamo farlo adesso
ma la cosa interessante
è che Hitler
non si riferisce
alla preparazione
degli eserciti
no
Hitler ha in mente
un'altra cosa
è un discorso famoso
questo di Hitler
ai suoi generali
del 22 agosto
Hitler dice
la guerra
dobbiamo farla
il prima possibile
finché ci sono io
perché non ci sarà
mai più
un leader in Germania
col mio potere
il mio seguito
ma io posso essere
fatto fuori
in qualunque momento
da un traditore
o da un idiota
è la cultura politica
di Hitler
che è tutta legata
al terrorismo politico
all'omicidio politico
è normale
può succedere
quindi finché non mi hanno
ancora ammazzato
facciamola questa guerra
e poi l'altra cosa
che dice Hitler
è anche finché c'è Mussolini
perché finché c'è Mussolini
ci possiamo fidare
dell'Italia
è l'unico uomo
che ha i nervi saldi
in Italia
quando non ci fosse più lui
si illude
si fida ancora
perché Mussolini
in quel preciso momento
ha già deciso
che lui si chiama fuori
ma Hitler
si illude ancora
sul suo vecchio amico
mercoledì 23 agosto
viene annunciato
sulla stampa mondiale
l'accordo
fra Germania
e Unione Sovietica
Corriere della Sera
l'accordo tedesco-sovietico
il grandioso successo politico
dell'asse
ha spezzato
la torbida manovra
degli accerchiatori democratici
stupore e smarrimento
nei paesi
antitotalitari
è una brutta parola
ovviamente
noi siamo totalitari
l'ha inventata Mussolini
la concezione
dell'essere un paese
è totalitario
quegli altri
mollaccioni
francesi
loro sono
antitotalitari
la Polonia
è sempre il Corriere della Sera
del 23 agosto
la Polonia
dovrà cercare
la sua salvezza
trattando rapidamente
con la Germania
la Polonia
sta cominciando a cedere
a pensare che forse
un accordo anche
con l'Unione Sovietica
anche col diavolo
si potrebbe fare
ma è tardi
quel 23 agosto
Ribbentrop vola a Mosca
e firma il patto
di non-aggressione
che viene reso pubblico
e firma anche
il protocollo segreto
che non viene reso pubblico
evidentemente
in cui la Germania
e l'Unione Sovietica
si accordano
per spartirsi
la Polonia
Hitler riceve
l'ambasciatore inglese
quel giorno
perché l'unica preoccupazione
che gli rimane è
ma l'Inghilterra
cerchiamo di tenerla fuori
comunque
Hitler riceve
l'ambasciatore inglese
e gli dice
gli parla di questi orrori
che i polacchi
stanno commettendo
contro la minoranza tedesca
in Polonia
qui c'è un piccolo dettaglio
che potevo sopprimere
come tanti altri
ma anche stasera
non ho avuto il coraggio
di sopprimere
troppi dettagli
dovrò tagliare corto
perché sto perdendo
troppo tempo
ma comunque
Hitler
è una conversazione morbosa
questa di Hitler
con l'ambasciatore inglese
sugli orrori
che i polacchi
stanno commettendo
contro i tedeschi
Hitler gli dice
mi risultano anche
molti casi
in cui dei tedeschi
sono stati castrati
dai polacchi
l'ambasciatore inglese
nel suo rapporto
a Londra
dice
per puro caso
ero
a conoscenza
di uno di questi casi
di un caso
l'epoca
il tedesco in questione
era un maniaco sessuale
che è stato trattato
come meritava
Hitler mi ha risposto
che lui conosceva
sei casi
non uno solo
e vanno avanti così
Hitler gli dice anche
questa cosa con la Polonia
è l'ultima
io sono un artista
non un guerriero
se sistemo questa cosa
con la Polonia
mi ritiro dalla politica
e mi dedicherò
all'arte
l'ambasciatore
riferisce a Londra
venerdì 25 agosto
Hitler
ordina l'attacco
per domani
poi riceve
una lettera di Mussolini
in cui Mussolini
per la prima volta
gli dice la verità
l'Italia
non è pronta
a fare la guerra
però non ha il coraggio
di dirgliela proprio tutta
quindi Mussolini
a Hitler
dice
guarda che ora
come ora
noi non potremmo
fare la guerra
avremmo bisogno
di grosse forniture
di materie prime
se la Germania
ce le può garantire
Hitler
ci rimane male
però ci casca
decide di rinviare
di qualche giorno
l'attacco alla Polonia
intanto chiede a Mussolini
ma esattamente
quali forniture
di materie prime
vi servono
sabato 26 agosto
Mussolini
e i capi di stato maggiore
delle forze armate italiane
si riuniscano
a Palazzo Venezia
per stendere
la lista
delle materie prime
da chiedere alla Germania
i generali
sono stati imbeccati
da Ciano
nel fare questa lista
nessun criminoso
ottimismo
cioè
voi capite
andateci giù pesanti
fanno la lista
ve la leggo
6 milioni
di tonnellate
di carbone
per capirci
è la produzione italiana
di due anni
2 milioni
di tonnellate
di acciaio
la produzione italiana
di un anno
7 milioni
di tonnellate
di oli minerali
un milione
di tonnellate
di legname
e poi rame
nitrato di sodio
sali potassici
gomma
toluolo
trementina
piombo
stagno
nichelio
molibdeno
tungsteno
titanio
20 tonnellate
di zirconio
la lista
è passata
alla storia
come
la lista
del molibdeno
la spediscono
all'ambasciatore italiano
a berlino
a tolico
l'ambasciatore a tolico
la porta a ribbentrop
ribbentrop
guarda la lista
e dice
ma entro
quando vi serve
tutta questa roba
dramma
perché a tolico
non hanno detto niente
lui non ha istruzioni
però ha capito
l'aria che tira
perciò
improvvisa
subito
è stato calcolato
che ci volevano
17.000 treni
per mandare
tutta quella roba
in Italia
ribbentrop
va da hitler
e capiscono
finalmente
mangiano la foglia
hanno capito
l'italia non ci sta
starà fuori
e va bene
pazienza
hitler scrive a mussolini
e gli dice
va bene
anche se l'italia
non può entrare in guerra
noi faremo da soli
ci basta che l'italia
non lo faccia sapere
che resterà fuori
se non lo sbagliere
andirate troppo
a noi ci aiuta già
e poi hitler dice
un'altra cosa
una piccola cosa
ma è indicativa
del futuro
dice potreste aiutarci
mandando degli operai
italiani
in germania
e qui in questo modo
così in sordina
comincia quella
che sarà poi
una lunga storia
e fa proprio vedere
come cambiano le cose
i tedeschi di colpa
hanno aperto gli occhi
dell'aiuto militare
dell'Italia
non ci si può contare
invece i lavoratori
si
comincia lì
tutta la storia
dei milioni di italiani
che prima saranno convinti
e poi costretti
a andare a lavorare
in Germania
domenica 27 agosto
viene introdotto
il razionamento
tessera per i generi alimentari
lunedì 28 agosto
l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
pensano ancora
che forse si potrebbero
convincere i polacchi
a trattare
e insistono
col governo polacco
andate a chiedere
ai tedeschi
esattamente
cosa vogliono
e vediamo
di parlarne
martedì 29 agosto
in Italia
scatta il divieto
di circolazione
per le automobili private
l'austerità
nei ristoranti
nei menu
si può mettere
una sola pietanza
o carne o pesce
ma una sola
l'ambasciatore inglese
va da Hitler
per vedere
se è possibile
davvero ancora
all'ultimo momento
un negoziato
l'ambasciatore inglese
scrive a Londra
Hitler questa sera
non era simpatico
è stata un'intervista
un incolloquio tempestoso
continuava a dire
che lui desidera
l'amicizia inglese
più di qualunque cosa
al mondo
ma non può sacrificare
gli interessi vitali
della Germania
però Hitler ha detto
comunque
se voi mi garantite
che i polacchi
davvero sono disposti
a trattare
va bene
che mi mandino
un emissario
da Berlino
domani
con pieni poteri
e possiamo ancora
trattare
mercoledì 30 agosto
in Italia
vengono sospesi
i campionati del mondo
di ciclismo
a Varese
esce il divieto
di vendita
del caffè
ai privati
anche al bar
divieto di bere
la tazzina
tutto il caffè
riservato alle forze armate
in Francia
è sospesa
la circolazione
dei treni
evacuano
lo zoo di Van Seyn
per mettere in salvo
gli animali
in tutte le capitali
si comincia a costruire
ripari antiaerei
e distribuire
maschere antigas
alla popolazione
perché loro erano sicuri
che la guerra
sarebbe cominciata
con tremendi
bombardamenti aerei
sulle città
a base di gas
asfissianti
quel giorno
mercoledì 30 agosto
il ministro degli esteri
inglesi
lord Halifax
lo stesso che due anni
prima diceva
Hitler
beh ma in fondo
le vostre rivendicazioni
sono comprensibili
quel giorno 30 agosto
lord Halifax
scrive all'ambasciatore
inglese a Berlino
dice
i tedeschi
vogliono un plenipotenziario
polacco a Berlino
oggi
ma è irragionevole
lo devono capire
anche loro
l'ambasciatore inglese
gli risponde
avevo fatto
la stessa osservazione
a Herr Hitler
ieri sera
mi ha risposto
che si può volare
da Varsavia
a Berlino
in un'ora e mezza
a questo punto
gli inglesi
disperati
per evitare la guerra
cominciano a fare
pressioni pesanti
sul governo polacco
non dovete
provocare i tedeschi
basta con questi giornali
polacchi
che scrivono articoli
contro la Germania
basta con la campagna
antitedesca
mandate subito
un plenipotenziario
a Berlino
per discutere
l'ambasciatore inglese
torna da Ribbentrop
gli dice
stiamo facendo il possibile
stiamo cercando
di consigliare
il governo polacco
che faccia la pace
che faccia un accordo
Ribbentrop
gli risponde
all'ambasciatore inglese
mi sembra
che i consigli
degli inglesi
finora
abbiano avuto
maledettamente
poco effetto
l'ambasciatore inglese
gli risponde
e lo riferisce
a Londra
gli ho replicato
che ero stupito
di udire un simile
linguaggio
in bocca
a un ministro
degli esteri
a questo punto
c'è una nuova commedia
però un po'
una commedia nera
alla tedesca
Ribbentrop
gli dice
sì noi avevamo preparato
le condizioni
per un accordo
con la Polonia
sono queste
e l'ambasciatore inglese
riferisce a Londra
dicendo
a questo punto
Herfon Ribbentrop
ha cominciato
a leggermi
questo lunghissimo documento
in tedesco
velocissimo
io siccome pensavo
che dopo
me l'avrebbe dato
non sono stato
tanto ad ascoltare
quando ha finito
gliel'ho chiesto
sono le condizioni
per la Polonia
per fare l'accordo
Ribbentrop
mi ha detto
ah no
è troppo tardi
doveva arrivare ieri
il plenipotenziario polacco
l'ambasciatore inglese
gli dice
ma non potreste consegnarlo
all'ambasciatore polacco
a Berlino
Ribbentrop dice
mai
non lo convocheremo mai
l'ambasciatore inglese
gli dice
ma se chiedesse lui
di essere convocato
Ribbentrop dice
beh in quel caso
potremmo anche vedere
l'ambasciatore inglese
che continua
cioè no continua
forse ha capito
che lo stanno prendendo
per il naso
perché scrive a Londra
quella sera
siamo al 30 agosto
è quasi finita
l'ambasciatore inglese
a Berlino
scrive a Londra
quella sera
dicendo questo colloquio
con Herr von Ribbentrop
è stato estremamente
sgradevole
durante tutta la serata
Herr von Ribbentrop
ha scimmiottato
Herr Hitler
al suo peggio
31 agosto
gli inglesi
dicono ai polacchi
mandate un plenipotenziario
a Berlino
o almeno
mandate il vostro ambasciatore
a bussare
che gli diano
le condizioni
per il negoziato
i polacchi rispondono
noi non mandiamo
l'ambasciatore
sarebbe troppo umiliante
a mezzogiorno
e 40 di quel 31 agosto
Hitler firma
l'ordine di attacco
per la mattina dopo
all'uno del pomeriggio
i polacchi ci ripensano
senza dirlo
agli inglesi
ordinano
all'ambasciatore polacco
a Berlino
Lipsky
di andare
da Ribbentrop
e chiedere
quali sono
le condizioni
per un negoziato
Lipsky va
da Ribbentrop
gli dicono
ma lei ha i pieni poteri
no
non li ho
allora no abbiamo niente
da dirci
e lo rimandano via
quella sera
c'è il famoso
incidente di Gleywitz
l'incidente di Gleywitz
è una cosa curiosa
e curiosa
soprattutto per questo motivo
dopo tutto questo
che vi ho raccontato
una persona di oggi
non crederebbe
che i tedeschi
avevano bisogno
di un pretesto
per dichiarare guerra
alla Polonia
invece vogliono
un pretesto
e i servizi segreti
tedeschi
al comando di Heydrich
l'hanno già preparato
il pretesto
Heydrich lo sapete
Reinhard Heydrich
pezzo grosso
dell'SS
capo dei servizi
di sicurezza
che sarà poi
ammazzato
giustiziato
quattro anni dopo
dai partigiani
cecoslovacchi
a Praga
Heydrich
ha preparato
un comando
già da due settimane
a Gleywitz
che è una stazione
radio tedesca
vicino alla frontiera
polacca
sono in attesa
dodici uomini
dei servizi segreti
tedeschi
con divise
e documenti
polacchi
pronti a entrare
in azione
appena è il momento
giusto
la mattina
del 31 agosto
è il momento giusto
Heydrich
manda al comando
la parola d'ordine
la nonna
è morta
il comando
entra in azione
in divisa polacca
in territorio tedesco
attaccano
la stazione radio
di Gleywitz
sparano
si impadroniscono
della radio
trasmettono
un comunicato
farneticante
come si diceva
da noi ai tempi
dell'Ebr
in polacco
e poi se ne vanno
lasciandosi dietro
un morto
in divisa polacca
quindi c'è stata
l'aggressione polacca
in territorio tedesco
i tedeschi
hanno il diritto
di invadere la Polonia
e cominciano
poche ore dopo
all'alba
del primo settembre
ma nel frattempo
nella notte
Lord Halifax
ministro degli esteri
inglese
il quale
spera ancora
che i tedeschi
siano sinceri
che si possa davvero
aprire un negoziato
con i polacchi
ed è preoccupato
perché questi stupidi polacchi
non vogliono
mandare l'ambasciatore
non sa che è già andato
il giorno prima
l'ambasciatore polacco
e l'han buttato fuori
Lord Halifax
ancora nella notte
sul primo settembre
manda
al suo ambasciatore
a Berlino
e a Varsavia
il telegramma
forse più insulso
che un governo britannico
abbia mai mandato
e cioè dice
ma non vedo
perché il governo polacco
non vuole
fare delle difficoltà
il suo ambasciatore
l'ambasciatore polacco
dovrebbe accettare
questo documento
del governo tedesco
un rifiuto da parte loro
sarebbe gravamente
frainteso
dell'opinione pubblica
il governo di sua maestà
è pronto a fare tutto
per aiutare
una mediazione
e all'ambasciatore
a Varsavia
dice
ma andate
dite al governo polacco
che il loro ambasciatore
deve andare
da Ribbentrop
subito
per salvare la pace
quella sera
l'ambasciatore inglese
a Varsavia
risponde
a Lord Halifax
il vostro telegramma
è stato decifrato
alle 4 di stamattina
il signor Lipsky
l'ambasciatore polacco
a Berlino
era già stato
dal ministro degli esteri
tedesco
alle 6 e mezza
ieri
in considerazione
di questo fatto
che è stato seguito
dall'invasione tedesca
della Polonia
stamattina
all'alba
è chiaramente inutile
che io esegua
le vostre istruzioni
passeranno ancora due giorni
prima che l'Inghilterra
e la Francia
si decidano
a dichiarare guerra
alla Germania
nella speranza
stavo per dire
la speranza disperata
e la stanchezza
non si può dire
ma insomma
nella speranza
folle
e ingenua
come dire
e in buona fede
che si possa ancora
evitare questa catastrofe
nel frattempo
in Italia
Mussolini tranquillo
Hitler ha accettato
che noi stiamo fuori
e quindi
stiamo a vedere
aspettando
come dice Ciano
di vedere se possiamo fare
anche noi
la nostra parte
di bottino
naturalmente però
alla stampa italiana
le veline
non dicono questo
la stampa italiana
deve dire qualcos'altro
quindi chiudo
con il Corriere della Sera
del primo settembre
le proposte di Hitler
per Danzica
le ali
ragionevoli
eseguibilissime
lasciate stoltamente
cadere da Versavia
e da Londra
Inghilterra
e compagni
inchiodati
alle loro tremende
responsabilità
la conscia saggezza
e la moderazione tedesca
di fronte
alla cieca intransigenza
delle altre parti
in conflitto
e questi sono i giornali
che leggevano i nostri padri
in questo nostro felice paese
nel 1939
grazie
grazie a tutti